face to face the leaders of the world's
two richest nations appear to have made
a breakthrough calling a temporary truce
to their escalating trade wars before
this highly anticipated meeting Donald
Trump had sent mixed signals to
President Xi saying he would press ahead
with raising further tariffs but also
that he was hopeful of a deal in the
room as their meeting kicked off he
suggested two and a half hours in donald
trump angie Jingping reached an
agreement that for now the US will not
increase tariffs on Chinese imports in
return
China will buy more goods from the US to
reduce the trade imbalance his dinner
was she became Trump's headline moment
at the g20 in Argentina after he
canceled his meeting with Russian
President Vladimir Putin Putin why do
you think Donald Trump canceled
the White House said that Russia's
increased aggression in Ukraine was the
answer the Kremlin suggested it might
have more to do with bad news back home
Trump also cancelled his news conference
tweeting that it was out of respect for
the passing of George HW Bush by his
standards
Trump's g20 summit was pretty muted but
things could be about to heat up at home
the questions that couldn't be asked
about the Russia investigation here in
Buenos Aires aren't going away
this summit fraught with diplomatic
tensions did manage a final statement
agreeing on reform of the body that
regulates global trade disputes but once
again the u.s. went its own way on
climate change the consensus the g20
strives for fills more elusive than at
any point in its 10-year history Amanda
Walker Sky News Buenos Aires